she's identified a number of failings
some official some political and some
that i accept are entirely my own for
which i take full responsibility
i want to start by saying that i'm
humbled by what has happened and i renew
my wholehearted apology
for the gathering in the cabinet room
on the 19th of june
2020 my birthday for which i received a
fixed penalty notice
now that sue gray has completed her
inquiry and everyone can read her report
i want in all humility and without
mitigating what has happened to offer a
few points of context
10 downing street is not just my
official residence but the headquarters
of the government where hundreds of
people work and because they directly
support the prime minister the
regulations allowed them to continue
attending their offices
for work purposes throughout the
lockdowns
sue gray describes them as tight-knit
groups of officials and advisors who
worked long hours under difficult
conditions
these were the public servants who
secured the ppe that saved many lives
established the biggest testing program
in europe and enabled the development
and distribution of the vaccines that
succeeded in protecting so many people
when some of these officials and
advisors were leaving their jobs i
briefly attended gatherings to thank
them for everything they had done
because i believe that recognizing
achievement and
preserving morale are essential duties
of leadership
the police did not find my attendance at
these occasions to be a breach of the
rules
but they found otherwise in respect of
some of those gatherings after i had
left or when i was not in the building
dining street and the cabinet office
together have hundreds of rooms and
again i say there's not in any way to
extenuate my personal responsibility but
to give context to these events
and i i was in particular appalled
to learn that there have been multiple
examples
in sue grey's phrase of disrespectful
and poor treatment
of cleaning and security personnel
and this afternoon i personally
apologized to those dedicated members of
staff
for what happened and i expect
anyone who behaved in that way to do the
same
as sue gray acknowledges i have acted on
her recommendations to make a series of
changes
10 dining street now has its own
permanent secretary charged with
upholding the highest standards i've
appointed a new leadership team
including a new chief of staff and a new
principal private secretary
and i've made it easier for any member
of staff to voice any worries they may
have
and sue gray says that she is reassured
by this reform
and it is precisely because i have
learned this lesson that i feel an even
greater
weight
of responsibility
to deliver on the priorities of the
british people and lead our country
through some of the most challenging
times in recent history i will work
every hour to ease the hardship caused
by the rising cost of living to protect
our nation from the aftershocks of
kovid to stand firm against putin's
aggression and unite and level up across
our united kingdom that is the mission
that drives this government and that is
the mission i will continue to pursue
thank you all very much for coming i'm
going to go to we're going to try and
get as many questions in as possible can
i just say one thing we'll have a chance
have more questions if everybody can
bear to confine
uh him herself to
one question each uh let's go
first to chris mason of the bbc
thank you christmas
to address our viewer today who hears
all of this and questions your character
your judgment your integrity and your
willingness to tell the unvarnished
truth bluntly
talk to our viewer convince our viewer
that you're not you're not tempted or
willing to lie to get out of a tight
spot
no i thank you very much chris and i
hope that uh the imaginary view is not
an imaginary view i hope we've got
several viewers uh right now uh i i just
say to the to to that uh person look
i've tried to explain
as clearly as i can uh what happened uh
why i said what i said uh to the house
of of commons uh the event for which i
uh have been found to be a fault i i've
tried to to explain the event in the in
the cabinet room
and
uh on on july 19 2020
um
where i was basically standing at my
desk for uh for a brief period
surrounded by uh some other some other
colleagues and then i've tried to
explain the context of uh why i was at
uh at other events where i was saying
farewell to to valued colleagues and i
just i know that people uh will think uh
it was
some people think it was wrong even to
do that i have to say i respectfully
disagree i think it was right when
people are working very hard uh
for very long hours uh when they're
giving up a huge amount to uh to serve
their country uh and that and they're
moving on to some other uh part of
government i think it is right to to
thank them or or leaving government
service all together i think it is right
to thank them and uh i repeat what i
what i said in the uh in the comments uh
earlier on um
you know uh i believe that they were
were work events uh it's they were part
of my job and
um
uh
that that view appears to be
substantiated by the uh the fact that i
wasn't fined
uh for those events
for the rest i just want to say you know
i i appreciate that things didn't go
in the way that i would want uh would
have wanted to they've the events
proceeded afterwards in
the way that uh i certainly wouldn't
have
wanted to see what happened with the
custodians was plainly
and the cleaners was plainly utterly
unacceptable and i i apologize for for
that as as i've apologized uh to them
personally
uh harry cole the son
uh thank you very much so on that point
sick was left in corridors winding up
the walls left for cleaners to to to
clean up
staff who work for you were rude to
security
members of this building what steps are
you taking beyond asking them to say
sorry and is there a place in your
administration for that sort of behavior
and if i may you were rather coy in the
house of commons early when asked
directly by one of your mps if you ever
asked sue gray not to publish her report
subsequent to the police investigation
do you want to clear that up now did you
infer at any point to sue grey that
publication might not be necessary
so so look on that it's never it's
impossible for the terms of reference
make it absolutely clear that sue
has got to publish
a report and i think it's entirely
right that she has and i think that the
um
you know what she's published is you
know you couldn't i don't think anybody
could reasonably say reading that report
that an awful lot has been swept under
the carpet to be absolutely frank with
with with you but you know
i would just say on the
um
uh
the
behavior of staff uh and
and and the alleged uh rudeness it is i
don't know who is
specifically
is guilty of that so in my in the course
of my
uh apologies today
i i
began to make some inquiries and i will
of course continue them and as i said
earlier on
if people
have been i think it's utterly
intolerable for people to be rude to
hard-working staff and
at the very least that they should uh
they should apologize but i don't yet
have the
uh the names of those who are uh who are
responsible
uh matt fry channel four
prime minister um we are sitting or
standing in your case in the place that
flouted the rules that were made here
more than any other institution in the
country you yourself have made history
by becoming the first prime minister to
break the law while in office
and you talk about other people who've
insulted stuff and so on but i want to
know what you think
your own personal failings were in
creating the culture that allowed this
to happen i think that i think matt you
the best thing i can invite you to do is
look uh very carefully at what sue
uh has said and if you if you if you
read her
report and you and you look at the
the detail in which she uh
describes when you talk about me my own
participation uh in the events uh what i
did uh how how long i was there and and
so i think you get a a pretty uh fair
picture of what took place that does not
mean
that i don't accept responsibility
for the totality of what happened and
yes
i
bitterly regret it and that's why we've
taken steps
since the interim report in particular
to to drive a lot of change in number 10
and the way number 10 works and and to
ensure that there are much clearer
lines of of command and everybody
understands you know the difference
between
uh being uh
engaged in in work and in socializing
and i think that is the uh that is the
crucial thing uh
jason gray's daily mail
thanks your principal private secretary
appears to have been
uh organizing parties against advice he
seems to be boasting about it uh about
getting away with it
why didn't you stop him and more broadly
is anyone in uh whitehall government
gonna face any sort of disciplinary
process as a result of this sorry saga
yes so first of all uh jason i don't
want to uh to comment on uh individuals
who are named in the in the report i
don't think it's right for politicians
to uh to talk about uh officials in in
that way uh any official um what i can
say is that
um
i i think that
uh
we've all we've all
no so i want to be clear i i i didn't
know that for instance i uh
you know a lot of the stuff that i saw
in the report uh this morning uh you
know was news to me uh but um
i i think it's important let me put it
this way i think it's important that
the
uh
everybody who everybody who's named
everybody and everybody who hasn't been
there everybody who's in any way
involved in this whole
sorry business has got to learn the
lessons and that applies to uh to
everybody in the in the report
tom harwood gb news
uh thank you prime minister
the fines that were issued across
downing street and the whole of
whitehall
were for events that took place over
varying levels of restriction it took
months of investigation to determine
whether a number of edge cases broke the
rules that you set
or not indeed you said earlier in
parliament that it can be very difficult
to decide the boundary between what
qualifies as work and what qualifies as
socially socializing so in hindsight
were the rules that you set simply to
unclear too illogical
and too tight for too long and and just
if i may on another issue that really
does affect people up and down the
country real wages are projected to be
lower in 2026 than they were in 2008.
what are you going to do about it so
so first of all uh tom
the
on the on the rules i look i i
we had to implement and that this is a
controversial thing and there are many
people
who who think that you could have done
without uh restrictions you could have
done with you could just relied on
people's personal responsibility
the the difficulty was that we were
facing a pandemic of a kind that we'd
never seen before uh certainly not in my
lifetime uh its effects were were
unknowable and all the medical and
scientific advice was that you had to
proceed by non-pharmaceutical
interventions you had to get people uh
to behave according to certain uh rules
so i don't think the flaw was with the
with the rules tom i i've got you know
we should have we should have recognized
that the boundary between work events
and uh and socializing for people who
are curiously working together in the
same place uh was going to be hard to
draw and we should have we sh we you
know things should have been done
differently and they certainly are being
done differently uh from now on on your
point about incomes uh which is the
crucial thing and
look you know the the cobia pandemic
cost the government a huge it cost
taxpayers 408 billion just to
support businesses and support families
through the package it's left a very
difficult
fiscal position employment is very
strong some features of our of of our
economy are extremely strong but there's
no doubt because of the the global
supply chain shocks uh exacerbated what
by what
by what putin has done in in ukraine uh
by the uh the spike in the price of
energy
we're going to see pressures for a while
to come i've just got to be realistic
with people about that we're going to
see pressures on
on household finances so what i'm saying
to people is that we will uh continue to
respond just as we responded throughout
the the pandemic these it won't be easy
we won't be able to to fix everything
but what i would also say is that we
will get through it and and we will get
through it well and uh that we have
some fortunate fundamentals not least
you know the lowest unemployment rate
since 1974 that we have strong uh
a strong labor market we have a a lot of
firms who are looking to hire people
looking to to grow and that august well
uh for the future but there's no
question we have uh pressure now on
household finances everybody knows it
everybody can feel it and believe me the
government is going to do everything we
can to help people
let's uh go to
esther weber that's the weber politico
no i'm gonna say um given everything
we've heard and what you said about the
boundaries not being properly drawn
what can you say to reassure us that you
and the officials you appoint the top
jobs
are capable of being the grown-up in the
room
thank you uh esther i think that
it
i mean just
on me in particular and and uh
my
role
um i i just you know remind you of what
i have said and i don't hope i won't
seem uh to be uh you know uh pernickety
when i say that
um
i
thought the things that i was attending
were work events i thought that my job
was to to thank people for uh their
contribution to to public life to the to
to government service
but you know plainly uh
we all made mistakes and we have to
learn from them um it is
it is no mitigation but it is it's
helped set the context that these were
really really exceptional circumstances
uh but then they were exceptional for
everybody in the country and and i
accept that
uh beth rigby skye
prime minister
vomit drunken altercations security
staff being treated with contempt
cleaners having to mop up red wine
sue grey's is a shame in dossier really
isn't it of what's meant to be the place
the heart of government that sets the
standards of our country
and it's your culture under your
leadership did you never for a moment
during the past five months or even this
morning when that report landed on your
desk and you read it blow by blow think
about resigning a poll out today just
out says three in five britons think you
should yes i look and uh beth i of
course i understand uh why people are
um uh indignant and and uh i
and why people have been angry at what
uh what took place uh all i can say is
that i really think that given
everything that is going on right now uh
it's my job to get on and serve the
people of this country uh not just to uh
get us through the biggest war in europe
for uh for
70 years uh but the a huge spike in uh
the the cost of uh of living and to
deliver
our manifesto commitments on which i was
uh elected uh with a large majority i so
i i i i hear you i i understand you uh
but i i really feel it's my job to
to to get on was there any point you
thought about it though because during
any of it did you ever think this why
are only you allowed to come back better
than some special position okay forgive
me
well look i mean i just i just repeat my
uh my point i i think that
um
i've i overwhelmingly feel it is my job
to get on and uh and deliver and and no
matter how
bitter and painful the conclusions of
this may be and they are
and no matter how humbling they are i've
i i i've got to uh keep moving forward
and the government's got to keep moving
and we are and you know just
this week
we're getting on with things that again
delivering on things that have been left
undone for a very long time trying to
fix the the legacy uh issues in in
northern ireland incredibly difficult
thing to do a government for decades
have have shirked it uh but we're
getting on and doing it and i was i was
pleased to see that um you know at least
you know peter mandelson is supporting
what we're what we're doing even if the
uh the current opposition uh is not uh
we will get on and continue to do the
tough things uh
jess elgot the guardian
prime minister
people in this room
told us
that there were no parties people from
your press office told us there were no
parties
and we now know that parties took place
in the press office
were those people told to lie to us and
do you concede now that they did lie
um well
jess i don't know exactly what they what
they told you but by my having talked to
people in this in this building about
what happened and what was said
it's it's my strong impression that they
genuinely believed that what they were
doing
was working and they were working around
the clock and they did not think that
what they were doing was in conflict uh
with the rules that's what they that's
what they told me
and so
i certainly don't think that they say
they set out to
uh to deceive you about that uh but
plainly uh
if you look at what sue has has found
and if you look at what the met have
found that simply wasn't right
and we've got to accept it um and we've
got to to recognize that mistakes were
made
and
um
we've got to cont i've made a lot of
changes already and we'll continue uh to
make changes but i think the the best
thing i can do is is
continue to
repeat the apologies that i've that i've
given but also to stress that i think we
we just have to uh to try if we if we
possibly possibly can to continue with
the
the people's priorities and we certainly
can and we will on that point paul brand
itv
i mean so you said so far
this afternoon that some of this rule
breaking was news to you
you told mps you told us all
categorically that no rules were broken
but this is your home you saw what was
going on you participated in what was
going on you made the rules as prime
minister so it does beg the question
are you a liar well uh paul i think
you've uh
no but look at the uh what i said to to
parliament and look at what sue has said
uh about what what took place and
about my my role in it um
i i i
just to get back to
what i said i think in the in the first
answer um
okay i was in the the cabinet room
for a short period standing up at my
desk
on june 19th 2020
and some people
came in
to
congratulate me on my birthday
now
there weren't very many of them uh it
didn't occur to me then that this was a
breach of the rules i'm going to be
absolutely frankly it didn't occur to me
it really didn't and i think you know
that that's just that's just the way it
was
similarly when
i was um
speaking to
uh to colleagues
about the departure of
another
spad or a government advisor or an
official
it didn't occur to me that this was
anything except what it was my duty to
do
as prime minister during a pandemic and
that's why i did it
and that's why i spoke as i did in the
house of commons
and yes as as sue has found
and
uh as everybody can see and as the
evidence
as has shown after
uh i had been there things
did not go well
and music or partying no no no i i've
there's there's there's a
uh let's let's be absolutely clear this
is a very very big place there there are
there are
uh if you take number 10 in the
uh cabinet office together there are
hundreds of uh of rooms
you know uh
my impression was that i was at
i was personally at work events but look
that doesn't
get your
that doesn't absolve me of
responsibility for what happened in this
place
i take that responsibility
i
continue to
make sure that we
make changes uh i've apologized today uh
not just again to the to the house and
to the country but also to the
custodians and uh and the staff
uh who uh it now it turns out were
wrongly and badly treated i think it's
it's repugnant that that happened
but
i think
the best thing i can do now without in
any way wishing to
minimize what has happened is simply get
on uh with delivering on the priorities
of the of the people and uh that is what
uh we are going to do with it and i'm
i'm sorry to say i i have to
to to to leave you all now uh
okay i'll take i'll take i'll take three
more questions but i'm under strictly i
was i'm not restricted instructions to
agree to no more than nine but such is
my natural generosity of soul uh i i i
will i will go to
uh to pippa
from the mirror
do you say that sue gray that no um
individual gathering was swept under the
carpet by sue grey but there was one
very striking omission which was the
gathering in your flat on november 13
2020 which she started investigating and
then says in her report that she paused
when the police started looking at it
and then concluded after the police
closer investigation that she wasn't
going to carry on that investigation so
in the absence of any other explanation
what were you your wife and five aides
doing for several hours with alcohol and
snacks in your flat that evening
specifically did you or any of your
senior political team see her report
before this morning and either have any
role in editing it or requesting the
removal of any facts about gatherings
and dining so so
um the first i saw the the report and uh
read it in its entirety uh was was at uh
and to the to the best of my knowledge
the first of any of my team uh saw it
was that uh
uh when we got it at ten o'clock which i
think shortly after ten o'clock uh this
morning and when i said when i said
earlier on somebody said there were
things in it
that were there were news to me what i
meant by that there were there was there
was evidence and stutter and details
that i i
simply hadn't heard before and maybe
maybe they'd have been published before
but i certainly hadn't i hadn't heard
them
so on the on the uh the the downey
street flat what sue says in her
uh previous uh interim report is the
flat has a dual use it historically
prime ministers have used it uh for
meetings uh the event in question uh was
a uh a work
meeting and um
that was
what the uh
the metropolitan the metropolitan police
did investigated and uh that was
certainly the outcome
of their investigation
andrew andrew from lbc it's absolutely
blatantly obvious from sue gray's report
that the staff involved knew they were
breaking the rules they talked about
going out by back entrances avoiding the
cameras and so on you told us you told
the house of commons you told the
british people again and again that no
rules were broken when those stories
started to come out about the parties
did it never occur to you to ask around
and find out what had happened yes of
course and that's when i instituted the
the inquiry um who's who's next did you
start
well look i mean you know
ben
promising i know you don't want to get
into specific people but the report does
clearly lay out a lot of evidence about
martin reynolds who ran your private
office
he uh invited everyone to bring your own
booze but
her party he said um he thought they got
away with it he is still in your
government he's in the foreign office
and reportedly he's being sent on an
ambassadorial post can you explain to
the public why you're keeping him in
post look i'm not i really really am not
going to get into the business of uh
um
identifying any particular official uh
uh over any other or anybo
or political appointee or or anybody uh
in this whole uh affair i think it's uh
it's right so in the in the in the
pictures uh that we've that uh sue gray
has put out i think it's entirely right
that i should be the one who is not uh
pixelated uh i'm the i'm the i'm the
person at the uh the top uh i'm i'm
making the changes i've i instituted a a
a
a an inquiry i don't think anybody i
just repeat my point i don't think
anybody could fairly say uh that what
sue gray has done is to uh cover things
up or put things under the under the
carpet it is it is a very thorough and
extensive uh piece of work uh it covers
all sorts of events what we need to do
now is learn from what happened and
and
i'm not saying i minimize what has
happened but we have a huge huge amount
of business the government is getting on
with right right now mainly to do with
the cost of living mainly to do with the
uh the economy and we really need to
focus on that and with that i'm afraid
having given three more three more uh
answers and i that i like than than was
promised i'm going to love you and leave
you thank you thank you
uh boris johnson leaving his press
conference there answering a number of
questions more than he planned
about the findings of the sue grey
report a damning report with details new
details that the prime minister said
some of which were even new to him
being put out there in the public domain
it is four o'clock you're watching the
sarah j me show live from downing street
today coming up we'll have more on the
highly critical verdict on rule breaking
gatherings here at downing street and
across whitehall the report warns
behavior fell well short
this long-awaited 60-page document
publishes new photographs of gatherings
as the senior civil servant concludes
they should not have been able to happen
details of some events include excessive
drinking causing one individual to be
sick
and a minor altercation between two
members of staff
and the prime minister has told mps that
he takes full responsibility but in the
last hour he has been defending the
decision
to what he calls mark his staff's
departure